[Musique]
on va en parler de ce sujet avec diane
bérard et nicolas duvernois notre ca ce
soir bonsoir
françois legault donkey geneviève guide
book qui ont annoncé ces mesures là
contre les individus qui contreviennent
aux mesures d'urgence alors 1546 plus ni
frais pour les rassemblements privé à la
maison si on obtempère paul consorts pas
justement contre la maison rassemblement
lieu dans les lieux publics
faire des manifestations servent à ce
que vous en pensez quoi diane d'erreur
de bord mais c'est clair qu'on est
arrivé au moment où il fallait sévir
c'est clair qu'il y allait avoir on
allait arriver à cette étape là moi j'ai
écouté religieusement à 17 heures le
discours de monsieur legault chute du
premier ministre tout à fait d'accord
avec ça mais je reste sur ma faim quand
il quant aux données qui nous permettent
d'expliquer pourquoi on ferme certains
secteurs et tous que d'autres c'est si
on est rendu à un moment où après
plusieurs mois de pandémie
on a besoin de chiffres on a besoin de
faire on a besoin de donner je sais que
notre premier mené se répéter plusieurs
fois que c'était pas arbitraire mais
j'aimerais comprendre pourquoi on ferme
un théâtre où on reste une heure pour
une représentation quand une session de
magasinage doit durer au moins une arme
que la wii ça devient extrêmement
complexe pour le gouvernement et je
crois qu'il faut jouer la carte de la
transparence à 100% d'accord avec diane
il va falloir vraiment que le
gouvernement ouvre son jeu il nous
explique les décisions qu'ils prennent
autant les statistiques ils obtiennent
de ce qui se passe en ce moment mais
autant aussi les études de cas où les
comparatifs dans d'autres régions du
monde dans d'autres pays
je crois que c'est vraiment un travail
collectif l'expo ferme et c'est un
casse-tête kafkaïen peu importe la
décision qu'ils prennent une partie de
la population qui vont être contre cette
décision
donc j'aimerais vraiment à leur place et
vous aider vous avez bien raison mais je
l' ai déjà dit puis je le redis la joue
comme au le gouverneur de l'état de new
york des présentations tous les jours
avec des graphiques avec des données
avec des données très très précis je
comprends pas qu'au québec on n'arrive
pas à faire ça avec des données aussi
précises
je veux vous demander ce que ça vous
apparaît plus utile faire ce qui a été
annoncé aujourd'hui en fin de journée
c'est à dire faire intervenir les
policiers pour combattre la transmission
du virus que de serrer la vis aux à des
secteurs de l'économie vite fermé des
secteurs de l'économie diane moi je
commence à m'inquiéter qui est
l'instabilité sociale qui s'installe je
m'inquiète pour le moral des gens
je pense que c'est important
d'intervenir que les policiers
interviennent parce qu'il ya des règles
qui ont été clairement dit mais je
continue à penser que ça nous prend du
temps j'aime ça nous prend des
informations savoir pourquoi on cible
certains secteurs plutôt que d'autres
l'idée de donner des exemples je suis
pas vraiment à l'aise avec soin
d'utiliser certains acteurs en exemple
parce que c'est plus visible
j'ai donné des exemples de partir des
secteurs de l'économie
non ce que je veux dire c'est de se
servir de certains exemples de certains
secteurs plus visible pour donner des
exemples vous envoyez nous sommes très
bas nous contrôlons virus je parle de la
culture je parle des bas revenus note
aura donc j'appuie 100% le fait qu'il
faut stopper cette pandémie mais je
commence à avoir de l'inquiétude après
plusieurs mois sur l'absence de donnée
l'absence de faits pour les décisions
nicolas là-dessus mais je crois qu'on
est en train de passer d'une guerre
sanitaire vers une guerre psychologique
oui il va falloir et grâce justement à
on revient au point avant à l'ouverture
et la transparence aux familles fameux
shark là qu'on voit dans un groupe au
monde parce que tous les jours des
tables et greffiers à la population le
loup est exactement expliquer à la
population pour qu on prend ces
décisions là qui on le voit dans la face
d'un visage des dettes de nos leaders
ils sont pas contents non par exemple
devoir annoncer des obligés d'annoncer
ça bon ils doivent le faire la sale job
c'est pas évident pierre fitzgibbon on
va annoncer demain un plan de soutien
pour les restaurateurs pour les
entreprises nathalie roy va le faire
pour la culture vendredi
qu'est ce qu'il faut nicolas d'abord à
tout prix mettre dans ce programme pour
aider les industries touchées
passé au travers mais c'est sûr qu'il
faut éviter totalement un effondrement
littéralement de l'industrie charles
arrestations aux barrages par la culture
par l'hôtellerie aussi qu'on parle
peut-être un peu moins la culture la
culture du québec c'est cette chanson on
est satisfait mais ça s'est fait
distancer secret en sorte qu'on garde
notre identité ça c'est super important
je reprends le point à diane ou pas on
peut pas aller voir un film ou une pièce
de théâtre d'un du neuf québécoise mais
on peut aller à magasiner dans une
chaîne multinationale américaine qui
font leurs vêtements pas [ __ ] c'est
vraiment
il ya des questions aussi comme ça avait
plus profonde à se poser c'est sûr que
la restauration départ il faut il faut
les aider pour les supports milliers des
dizaines de milliers d'emplois moi je
pense qu'il faut s'attaquer aux frais
fixes il faut aider ces secteurs là à
contrôler et à payer leurs frais fixes
parce que ça fait des locaux vacants
ça fait une chaîne ça fait un effet
domino donc je pense que dans les
mesures essentielles
il ya tout ce qui a rapport aux frais
fixes ok je vous emmène sur le musée des
beaux-arts de montréal nous avions
caroline kotick est une nouvelle
administratrice
il ya quelques instants en entrevue on
part on peut parler d'une sorte de
renouveau là parce qu'il ya des nouveaux
membres
il ya le sud de la chaudière qui était
président qui était devenu ex-président
et qui finalement n'a pas vu son mandat
être renouvelé c'est un renouveau
nécessaire diam je pense que ça prend un
nouveau non pas juste des membres mais
des pratiques car aller nous parler de
l'institut de pratiques vieillissant je
pense que des questions fondamentales
qu'ils étaient entreposés par exemple
est il normal qu'on ait des donateurs
sur les conseils d'administration des
institutions culturelles jusqu'à date on
l'a pas remis en question ça semble une
pratique qu'on fait quoi faudrait de
remettre en question mais parce que
c'est ça sent le conflit d'intérêts si
j'ai fait un don au musée que je suis
sur le ch pourrait tenter d'influencer
de quelle façon les collections vont
être mises en valeur les collections que
dont j'ai fait don donc ces malaises à
moi j'ai toujours eu un malaise avec le
fait que des bénéficiaires des bailleurs
de fonds
tout tout tout ses parties prenantes ont
voix au chapitre mais doivent-elles
nécessairement à être sur l'océan et
décisionnel je pense que l'histoire du
musée des beaux-arts ouvre une ouvre la
boîte de pandore et rénales et des
regards nichol de la chenelière est un
grand donateur en culture dans les arts
et au musée pierre bourgie est un grand
donateur collectionneur qui a présidé le
qui a été sur le ca de 2009 à 2018 qui
est actuellement le président et qui a
été président du groupe de travail sur
la fine entre pie culturel en 2013
je comprends l'intérêt là mais je vous
pose un peu nicolas répond dr salah
pourquoi il faudrait
saucier actuellement le fait d'être
administrateur et d'être grands
donateurs
premièrement l'entrevue avec caroline
était absolument exceptionnel
connaissance d'un caveau lille elle ne
va pas lâcher le morceau ici dit teulé
contre quelqu'un j'aimerais pas contre
elle deuxièmement c'est extrêmement
incestueux tout ce qui se passe dans
cette histoire on dirait une série
anglaise là où il ya toujours des
mystères des non-dits toujours les mêmes
personnages qui revient beaucoup d'
influence beaucoup d'argent beaucoup de
pouvoir je trouve que c'est malsain pour
l'institution et on passe sous silence
on est en train qu'on a massacré
complètement la réputation d'une
superstar du monde dollars sur la
planète
nathalie bondil il faut connaître là
pour savoir à quel point elle lit elle a
une réputation hors pair ensuite nous
sommes allés nulle à moi je suis obligé
de vous ramener j'adore le climat de
travail dit que j'ai un problème
significatif moi j'en sais rien mais le
rapport qui a été demandé par le
gouvernement dit qu'il y avait un
problème significatif parce que ça
compte
so lu ment ici plus qu'important
cependant on lui a pas donné une chance
de creuser dans dans cette direction là
pour pouvoir arriver avec des solutions
selon le rapport même le rapport est
plus ou moins concret sur le mauvais
climat la vague qui dont on dénonce est
ce que c'était vraiment ça fout tout on
ne peut comprendre que c'est un autre
des dirigeants du musée vers toutes et
tous des commandes dans l'inconnu
l'indien voulez vous moi je dirais une
charge directe un climat de travail ça
se détériore en deux mois ou en trois
mois qui ça se rebâtit pas de moi ou à
trois mois donc si le climat de travail
était vraiment détérioré ce que je crois
ça fait longtemps que ça a dû se
détériorer donc pourquoi ça sort
maintenant les administrateurs ont fait
quoi
tout ce temps là depuis quand ils savent
ce qu'est ce qu'ils ont fait combien
temps ils ont donné quelles mesures ont
été un plan du hockey on verra pour la
suite parce que madame claudine nous dit
que ça va peut-être pas vraiment encore
bras coc a de toute évidence diane que
la merci beaucoup merci
bonsoir moi